that's right with the touch input type
in particular we can easily get multiple
touch move events inside a single
rendering frame refresh it's pretty
silly to try to paint the screen
multiple times during a single video
frame we're just wasting work like we
learned about in the last lesson on
performance so it's even more important
when writing touch event handler code to
not actually draw things inside that
touch event handler but actually buffer
them up and paint them inside a request
animation frame handler now you may have
noticed that inside my synthesizer i'm
actually setting classes which cause css
refreshes in response to touch messages
this could be a problem except that
setting that class happens relatively
infrequently it only happens when you
transition from one key to another so
it's not causing multiple refreshes per
paint cycle which is what we're really
trying to avoid